[Música]
hace tutoriales de maquillaje siendo
hombre defender los derechos de las
personas lgbti o tener comportamientos
sugestivos hacia una persona al mismo
sexo por hacer esta clase de videos
estos tres jóvenes influenciadores han
tenido serios problemas con las
autoridades autistas a causa de esta
foto publicada por su hail aljamel El
joven fue encarcelado por desnudez en
línea la tiktok que era Tala SAP Juan
también fue detenida después de haber
publicado una conversación con una amiga
fue acusada de su gestión propensa a
tener un impacto negativo en la moral
pública por su parte Mohamed albocar y
fue declarado culpable de promoverla
homosexualidad en línea y de imitar a
las mujeres nuestro observador es un
activista Saudita exiliado en Estados
Unidos y se moviliza por las personas
lgbti perseguidas en Arabia Saudita
lancé una petición una organización sin
ánimo de lucro para exigir la liberación
inmediata de sus Air josusual Hyatt que
tiene 25 años
lo arrestaron por primera vez en 2018
presuntamente por haberse vestido como
una mujer y haber desobedecido a su
familia
fue liberado por buena conducta después
de haber memorizado el Corán después se
volvió estudiante en la universidad
Estatal de California
pero un día publicó una foto suya con un
traje de baño en la que se veía un poco
de cuero
regresó a Arabia Saudita para ver a su
madre y cuando llegó al aeropuerto en
octubre de 2019 fue detenido arrestado y
condenado a tres años de prisión y 800
latigazos
su sentencia debería terminar en octubre
pero no hemos tenido ninguna noticia
sobre su caso ni hemos sabido nada del
gobierno saudí
[Música]
es una influencia dura egipcia que vive
en Arabia Saudita
vivía tranquilamente su vida y publicaba
videos en línea
había un video de ella en tik Tok
hablando con una chica con la que quería
pasar un rato
y eso fue sacado de contexto Se tomaron
fragmentos y le hicieron parecer un
miembro de la comunidad lgbt
tampoco sabemos que está pasando con su
caso
alguien pregunta para ti Qué significa
la homosexualidad
cada uno es libre de vivir como quiera
las personas gays También tienen
derechos
Entonces espero que dejen vivir a las
personas gays y no interfieran en sus
vidas
fue detenido en 2020 por haber publicado
Este vídeo y condenado 10 meses de
cárcel desde la llegada al poder del
príncipe heredero muhammadín Saudita
trataba de mostrarse más liberal y
abierta al mundo pero las personas lgbti
no se han beneficiado de esta política
supuestamente más tolerante la
homosexualidad es considerada una idea
extremista penalizada con cárcel y
flagelación
[Música]
ese proyecto la comunidad en la Favela
se río florecen las iniciativas
positivas que favorecen el desarrollo
sostenible y la reinserción social una
de ellas lanzada por la municipalidad de
ríos se ha vuelto muy popular nuestro
observador Yuri López Cruz es de biólogo
y creció en el complejo do alemao un
conjunto de favelas en la zona norte de
Río de Janeiro ahora trabaja en unos
jardines urbanos llamados hortas
cariocas la huerta de la Favela de
mangüinos es la más grande de América
Latina porque alimenta 800 familias
al pensar en las favelas y en banguiños
la gente solo se imagina lo peor que
puede pasar pero en la Favela hay un
programa mucho más importante es hortas
cariocas ese programa emplea más de 20
personas que producen alimentos y se les
dan a la gente más necesitada en la
Favela de manguiños
hay 276 personas en el programa hortas
cariocas y 56 huertas
producimos alimentos Bio gracias a las
técnicas de la agroecología acabamos de
obtener una certificación biológica
según y uno de los principales problemas
urbanos es debido a la violencia en la
favelas
la policía del río es una de las más
agresivas del mundo suele utilizar
camiones blindados y helicópteros para
realizar operaciones militares en la
favelas pero esas operaciones son más
aparecidas asaltos y tiene un impacto en
el proyecto en el que participa nuestro
observador vivir en una Favela Es vivir
todos los días en operaciones policiales
escuelas que cierran centros de salud
que cierran comercios que cierran todo
cierran los niños se quedan en la casa y
no pueden salir a jugar los niños son
asesinados entonces claro nuestro
programa también se ve afectado
cuando hay una operación policial no
podemos trabajar
entrena las favelas disparando por todas
partes lanzando granadas asocian toda la
Favela al tráfico
[Música]
es la criminalización de la pobreza
y de esta manera llegamos al final de
nuestro programa por esta misión
recuerde que todos nuestros contactos
aparecen en pantalla para que usted
envíe sus vídeos y fotos aficionados
hasta una próxima oportunidad